and we are live flashpoint
let's go naughty boxes oh not much you
know just live in the days and see you
know what comes our way through destiny
so and distracted by other games
recently but definitely still keeping in
tune with the Bungie feed so although
you know you had your trip last week but
welcome back to these states thank you
say thank you sir like I said it sucks
to be away but I had to take care of
some family business and uh like I said
just a funeral and uh other things
personal things going on and I have to
take care of and UK but a shout to you
you can't show a lot of love you know I
mean when I was out there but I was good
to be back good to be talking destiny
and uh we got a special guest today we
got the doctor in the building that
amnesia are you doing surfers what's
going on with you record you know for
those are listed it don't know like this
is the man that broke the internet like
this is the bed who would you look at
reddit right now if you see that article
is screen right now want is how destiny
to has failed its fan base this is the
man who literally has shattered read it
I think it's up to about us check 8,000
in counting hits and before we get into
our normal flashpoint in the swab and
all that good stuff um I wanna I want to
talk to it to doctors about his
background and also just like you know
what led him to create that article that
has the community like in such a frenzy
right now so doc the floor shows I guess
you could say I'm a freelance games
journalist I'm no I'm not like you know
like like Jason Schreyer or somebody
amazing like that who goes around and
does like interviews with people and all
that cool stuff I uh what I do is I do
deep dives into mechanics so I look at
what makes the game work why it works
all that stuff and I try to explain it I
you know when I was really
you swatch things like Bill Nye or
Mister Rogers or whatever and you know
they'd always explain how things work
they make me just smarter as a result
you know I want I wanted to kind of be
that for people when I read about games
because most people are writing about
like you know here's what the fans are
doing or just with the you know here's
where the developers did behind the
scenes you know and I don't have any of
that access I'm just a you know poor kid
in Kansas so I started talking well you
know here's what you like the game
you'll anchor here's what you don't like
the game you don't so i one thing I've
always wanted to do when destiny after
destiny to came out it was clear that
there were some problems I really wanted
to interview like Chris Barrett I
haven't really got to nice so I really
wanted to do that so I pitched it and
they got back to me at you a skimmer and
cat might want her there she goes she's
the editor-in-chief actually she goes uh
she's like I'm not really sure about
that piece but we were planning to do
one about why destiny to is kind of like
doing so poorly so did you talk about
that so I was like sure I will
absolutely talk about that because you
know I mean I love the game I have you
know a thousand something hours in the
first game you know over a hundred in
destiny too but I'm not really feeling I
ended up installing it to predict what's
going on right now which is this is
probably gonna sound bad but I actually
uninstalled it so I could play
battleborn oh good I was just I needed
the space
you know I'd like to reinstall to play
at some point but it wasn't the loot
chase or whatever and all this stuff and
you know I've seen people write they
come out in this sort of hardcore
defender that's just your opinion or
whatever so I sat here with this piece
and I my thinking was like how can I
convince someone especially yeah ideally
someone at Bungie right like thinking
sit there you know across from a table
with somebody a Bungie and tell them why
I uninstalled destiny to what would I
tell them mm and you know like um I
think PC gamer did a piece week or two
ago that was like you know these are the
updates that we want the most it was
weird stuff like free silver dust and
all this stuff and um rummy is smell
whoo
is a indie developer he kind of he was
not a fan of that piece was like oh it
would totally break the game you don't
know what you're talking about Melissa
so I wanted to make sure that I was
avoiding kind of the pitfalls yeah a
little there like PC gamer and fall and
then see there's stuff I want to make
sure that like anyone who could read my
piece could at least go I understand
exactly what you're talking about
II no not at the very least people read
it and go this makes sense so with that
in mind I try to be as clear as humanly
possible with this piece in it one thing
that helps is uh I got a job as a
freelance game consultant so I actually
get to talk to real developers nice face
to face sometimes literally across the
table about their games and whether the
games are working or not
unfortunately this will NDA so it's not
which means you can't divulge on
flashpoint yeah that sounds so cool
they'd like to be able to because I mean
ever what does everybody want they want
to give me to be fun enjoyable whatever
the purpose is you can actually be like
it is it isn't that sad that sounds
really really cool yeah it's it's really
neat because a lot of different
questions about what they want and so
like my job there has been to sort of
help them make the game better and so
there were some people who responded to
my piece going like one thing that they
really liked about it is it's not like
angry or hateful or whatever it's very
cleared it was like well you know my
thing was to go like yes I start that
piece and I did as much as I could to
prove factually that the game is
performing poorly because the first
thing I wanted to do is make sure that
people know one goes like hops and goes
destiny is okay and I'm defending it
everything is fine like I wanted to be
clear nothing is fine and we have to fix
it mm-hmm and you got that across very
well and and what I really want to
stress is that I don't mean you spoke
offline earlier the strength about the
article is that again it's not coming
from this like very inflammatory place
it's coming from a passionate
perspective and this is I know a lot of
the hardcore community feels and one
thing that I really liked is that you
have a gift of really articulating what
the community feels cuz I felt
everything you wrote down you're like
I've read her and was like yes yes yes
yes yes like all the way through him
like no yep absolutely
I'm literally smiling and shaking my
head and I'm like yes
yeah this is what I'm talking about and
and what I love that you did is you also
cited especially when you got into the
whack-a-mole section other if you scroll
down that to that party box is that like
it really nailed how Bungie sometimes we
just come Tom with an open like an over
heavy hand as far as a solution to
things we like with nerf a whole entire
class because one you know weapon you
know for example was over performing and
some like yeah so it you really
emphasize about taking the fun away
you know you could probably make it like
a book on some of that so yeah Katie
who's an amazing editor just like the
grammar fixes and the readability stuff
that yeah I'm sure they would throw my
work in the trash
he's my lord editor he he fixes my
little Katie came in she looked at it
she's like this section is really long
and I was like yeah it is but I find is
that like the fans like the Destiny fans
really love the detail yes honestly yeah
because if you you've put a thousand
hours and I put probably 2,000 hours and
I mean all of us have put when you put
that much time into something you're
gonna have some detail to talk about ya
know so I don't know if you guys
remember the the ldr nerf from ldr was
you know the best and it wasn't just the
best because it was it was a good gun
but it was like the best because they
nerfed everything else so you know I
described it as like
you know if the water levels are rising
in a flood its its people trying to find
the highest points they can you know
those high explain it to my brother back
in the day when we were talking about it
but it was like here's this gun that's
really popular and Bungie goes well it's
popular so we're gonna nerf it so I went
through that patch note I pointed out
that I think it's too much she'll just
know it knows it's not the old iwas
machine husband King smells got rifle
will you do much else with the Kings
fool what's the heavy machine gun from
the tech do that right now
coolest coolest hominis Willock willem
terminus terminus yes yes that one of
the nerf it in the exact same patch so I
talked about how ldr and terminus both
got these these sort of huge nerfs when
I would have rather seen guns I hated
using like do much else which is okay
like don't even get me started on some
of the king of all guns I I was like
they should be better right like they
all have awful stability and all this
other stuff like they're not fun in my
worst auto rifle ever ever hand cannons
trash I think that was when they were
just adding cocoon on everything right
yeah that's cool
I can't I think we only do it when
you're at zero ammo and you pick up the
ammo so you have to already it won't
work but like if you're an absolute zero
you will always get ammo reload it's a
nice kind of cool place thanks but you
know I saw I listed like all these times
Bungie hit did it and I felt that I was
you know buddy doing that I was kind of
explaining hey Bungie nerves all the
time but they're like you really only
need like one or two examples so you
know what's your nerve because I realize
that doesn't really apply to like
warlocks and Titans they generally get
lots of buffs as Bungie players but easy
on that warlock talk but I think
everyone I've ever met at Bungie or seen
play at Bungie is a warlock
like it's clearly
I can't I can't lie even even though I
will say this favoritism but I do for
from for you guys that are hunters I can
understand the frustrations let me look
at your class skill for destiny too that
alone probably covers the lack of love
for that class but like that just kind
of used to be a thing in destiny one yes
deserve better like here's an example
right if I punch somebody with my
throwing knife in destiny the throwing
knife just goes flying if I miss it just
it's gone I lost my skill if you punch
somebody in Miss with like your warlock
punch you get it back I mean you don't
use it it only uses if it connects and
so that's one of those things that
hunters just don't get for some reason
so how do several these disadvantages I
talked about it back when the beta came
out in like July right no you know I
hate the fact that unicorns got removed
from the game all this stuff mean but
for me that that part of the patch notes
where the guy from Bungie goes we don't
really know why this creates popular but
we're nerfing it anyways yet to me is
the best description of bungees
methodology that i've never seen so i
had to use that example because it's
like straight up going we actually don't
know why it's popular and it's like well
you talk to you talk to the players
you'd understand the reason that hunters
have the best like win rates in the game
me know if it's win rates it's pick rate
pratik more nick hunters than any other
class you know I'll just be honest
there's two reasons for it one is when
you're creating a character the cloak
looks cooler the best class item for
sure the cloak is pimp care Frank it's
obvious it looks cool like hood and
everything because you look badass so
you know I liked Titans more in destiny
more than destiny to you that the big
shoulder pad things aren't really doing
it for me a lean and Morlocks bond is
just like a tabata smack I'm a warlock
I'm like it's like a shoulder strap and
you're like come on yeah even if it was
like a shin guard it'd be probably so
which comes into the game the scrub
looks three characters and they're gonna
okay
looks coolest and yes I personally feel
that the hunter looks coolest I think
can be you know a majority of players a
small majority but they like the way the
hunter looks so then they get into it
and you find out that the hunter is like
the most agile character in the game and
so for a really long time
hunter is kind of dominated because they
get triple jump or the double jump with
bones of yo or whatever that that makes
them feel really good and with a warlock
I think that jump is a little bit like I
personally don't enjoy what it feels
gosh it oh that jump don't you mean the
flu really I think a really high level
player is all about the air game is
gonna be somebody who likes these really
precise yes jumps and so but you didn't
do anything with the hunter jumps and
they shouldn't because those jumps are
perfect they should have buffed the
other jumps um you know once players
discover the Titan skating glitch and I
insist that it's a glitch like there's
some guy in the red it was so mad at me
because he thought glitches could only
be bad things but like it's a really fun
glitch once you get those good players
like ninja with Noel and a few other
people I've seen just are phenomenal
Titan skaters once they got that thing
we saw more people playing Titans
because maneuverability is everything so
for some reason Bungie was like we're
just gonna remove the only solar sticky
curd ta about that you know it but it
felt good and it's the only solar
grenade that had a exotic so like
there's your reasons for using it right
um you know I don't like the other two
grenades I think they feel like garbage
like just personally the fire bolt in
the Solar I know uh I just don't have
fire bolt they have oh sorry you're
talking about
well I was thinking more like yeah they
have the swarm grenade which is just
like you throw it and then it creates a
really obvious trap that knows you're
ever gonna hit it's like it's like
Bungie wanted everyone to just see like
a neon sign screaming there's a hunter
Grenadier that they made - trapper
grenades you know one was trapper sticky
and that's what made it cool so you know
I think they gave it a buff
7% the the smart grenade and they
increased them the radius by like 0.5
meters but in a game as fast as destiny
as them yeah so I hoped that my like I
didn't want to do a whole piece that was
just Bungie screwed over hunters because
I could I could finally have 4,000 words
on my clan mates sinister he feels the
same way about in the beta I could
totally do a piece on it if you ask a
new rule you know wants to let me do it
that's really up to them
but I didn't want to do a whole piece on
that like I for me what I really want to
do is is I was like I have two main
concerns there are two things that could
really bring me back to destiny and so I
wanted to talk about them but I knew
that before I got there first I had to
prove there was a problem and then I had
to go okay I need everyone to understand
that this is how Bungie patches their
games and this is why I felt less
exciting and playing this it's like I
think at one point I actually had
speculation in there and speculation is
generally not good for these pieces but
that's speculation like once you made
destiny - as boring as it was just to
avoid having to ever patch the way that
they had to patch in destiny oh there's
some truth to that I feel there's some
truth to that
and yeah it's a reference to the
balancing because even they made some
statements initially when you know what
he was talking about hours and weapons
and and better Devils and stuff like
that you know there's some thought
process behind the the design you know -
and I definitely feel that there's
something in play as far as balancing
and making sure it's easier to balance
when these designs were came out in d2
but continue continue you know the
horrible special a moment you know nerf
with where icebreaker and sidearms are
the only good weapons to use you know
I'm like a thorn shotgun man I'm like
yeah we don't have to deal with some of
the really bad but I think smarter
tuning would have fixed it right you
know I think what they did is is they
removed all the power of fantasy and
they maybe should have just been okay
with you know it's like hey it's gonna
happen man like you're gonna have
you were always gonna complain about
certain things especially if you have
one-hit-kill weapons like they they put
all those one-hit-kill weapons into one
slot and it's like that's a horrible
that's over balancing right it's like
you know we complain about the grimoire
because it was not in the game so they
just removed grimoire score like the the
thing I would have wanted right because
I love hunting for ghosts I would have
liked to see the grimoire in-game so I
could read it I'm sure you've seen like
pipes archive video that he would do and
it's like that type of stuff would be
you know why remove it find a way to
have you I mean find a way to put it in
there and just make it even more obvious
and easy to access so if you want to go
back it's there exactly doing this kind
of thing for years and it always sucks
like Mass Effect they removed the the
make oh oh yeah
shanky it was terrible and also but in
Mass Effect 2 they just removed it like
why not make it better so you know
Bungie comes along they removed the
ghost hunt which is like one of my
favorite things oh oh yeah that was
amazing I never would have climbed the
mountain in rise of iron no one would
have you know they don't have any of
that so there's no reason to kind of
like observe the map you look for the
map marker that you're going to and you
run over to it there's no reason to
explore so that's a huge part of u2's
yeah the removal of a reason to explore
there's none of that
yeah they pulled it all out of the game
and so like I wanted to I wanted to make
sure that people at least understood my
my reasoning for why I felt the budget
needs to rethink how they're approaching
the game absolutely I put that in there
and then I brought up my two main points
which I've been making pretty much since
day one i don't think i'm adrien him
roll points as much but you know I got
to thinking about it later and of course
it started to become pretty popular and
read it I know there's some people who
like accuse me of cribbing the entire
article from reddit but I did put some
sources from reddit like when I think
I'm moving out right here like Slayer
into another people yeah I saw that I
was like hey he just repeated the point
that I made in July but you know there
was I think like somebody posted like
the
numbers of how many possible rules were
in the game right so that was really
useful for me to put in the article but
like my points for my points alone you
know like I've been arguing about the
weapon system since July since before
reddit thought it was a problem like
they were telling me I think I posted
back then I might have been on Twitter
but I talked about it before back then
and people like you're totally wrong -
primary's is amazing it primaries don't
have weaknesses as weapons they're just
really good like an all-around weapons
so of course when you have to it feels
even better right it just gets boring if
everything is always good having like
running into a crowd of thralls and
switching to your sniper and going oh
crap this is my sniper that that's a fun
moment even when you've messed up yeah
so I I wanted to make sure that people
understood hey the weapon system is bad
but then the loop chase is bad too
because I mean can you think of a single
loot game where the loot is static yeah
that that's been a point of contention
you know that that's definitely been a
point of contention and like I said
that's your section with the loop
shooter with no loot you know and if
they're even talking about it being more
of a collection game now you're like for
what what their legendary weapon kiosks
right you know like I mean think about
like Pokemon right it is gotta catch
them all just absolutely the collection
game to end all collection games
beginning with every single Pokemon is
random like every single one they all
may have the same sort of movesets but
they have different stats they have
different natures some of them are shiny
you know like every pokemon is random
and regularly important part of Pokemon
absolutely randomly random young life of
a single loot game in the entire world I
can't think of any game with a reward
cycle in the world that doesn't have
randomness to it except battlefield
because but I don't feel as you level up
you unlock certain specific weapons you
can call of duty I think yeah both of
those are about the same they're just
like opening progression as opposed to
loot like progression through
you know options is what I would
consider those and then as you say here
loot you want there in this because I
played World of Warcraft for I forgot
how many days and it's probably a bad
thing but I did yeah but that's the the
still ideas like you're going through
whether it's like you know you go
through a raid and when you did a
40-person right before you were waiting
for that cool thing and that cool bow
but even it even had stats but you might
not even one to get it so just a little
desire for those hard to find pieces
that could or could not have a good stat
gives you even more reason to go back
and none of that's there you know I've
heard some people on reddit at least say
that there are people from Bungie who
are bad at like picking the right skills
or you know somebody said today that
that guy who does sandbox is it was yeah
I believe so yeah yeah yeah they said he
said that like perks give him a headache
or something I don't know if that's true
right like I've never heard him say it
so I don't know you know I don't think
anybody's lying but that's just person
where I'm at and you know I feel like
well you know if you're working on a
game that has loot even if you don't
like it like this is the game you chose
to make this is the game you're employed
to make so you gotta make that loot
matter you gotta play you can't you
can't reward somebody you know as luke
says right there off-screen how can my
second third and tenth better Devils and
it came to be interesting like the only
way to randomly I think I have a larger
mag size better devil's master and you
get one extra bullet for that rare drop
of your favorite gun or you grind for
the course
yeah I actually for the course yes that
too I didn't never go into like wow one
extra bullet I mean at least fields go
back in year one gave me like what three
extra bullets for yeah for my fate
bringer and then a huge extra mag
increase like I think I had like you
know 30 or 40 extra bullets in my mag
for fate bring her back in the day
mmm-hmm my other that was just wait I
love bungee was when upgrades were large
and now they're like one extra bullet
and that's that when you go back to like
the perk discussion to as you're saying
they're about hung Cheerios like that
was an amazing gun I got a good one and
later on I got something that was almost
better cuz I've bought just we lost you
daki I know I got that really some guns
like to use but it really really annoys
me when you'll find like a scout rifle
and it's got a basically a duplicate
perk I see that on quite a few things
being a scout or a sniper and it's two
perks that almost do the same thing and
I'm like have some variety in the perks
or if you're gonna curate all these
things make them like help the gun type
like hmm hurts will ya sit there and
look at perks and they don't do anything
especially for a sniper rifle it's like
okay you're gonna boost a range or even
a scout rifle like they're good on range
they need help in other areas so uh I
was browsing my inventory for this new
piece I'm working on and cuz I wanted to
revisit this this loop part I'm gonna
talk about a little bit more in depth
and because it's a piece on now
basically the patch notes we want to see
for for destiny like and it's kind of
changed into more like this is what
would bring people back because like
zone shet is not gonna bring people back
no you know I don't think glory or
whatever that crucible thing is gonna
bring people back that can work a little
bit it's just lower no it's cool but I
don't think it's gonna bring people back
but I'm just going through my inventory
and I found this amazing cryptic dragon
that is it's got outlaw and explosive
rounds on it in the moment like wow that
is that is a better scout rifle and it's
rant that was a random drop like there's
a create one so it's not a vendor role
has he never sold it
um you know I mean senemo it makes more
accurate outlaw lets it reload faster
and explosive rounds on cryptic dragon
is like the perfect cryptic dragon to
begin with mm-hmm you know that's better
than nameless midnight and I love
nameless yeah I'm a huge fan enables
Minh
feels great it looks great especially
now that I have the black and gold skin
on it
like I love my nameless midnight but my
cryptic dragon craps all over it and
nice I rather you know I would rather
see my cryptic dragon in destiny to then
continue défis me to that end I'm
planning on doing all the raids in
destiny one probably wants to bring
break time when my brother's out of
school I I'm telling you I would love to
do all the raids weekly in destiny one
right now rather than trust me I hate
you it I totally hate so just I just
want to wrap up what we would talk about
referencing articles so now that you
like it's got out there it's got to
traction you know we've seen you know
shout out to destiny Gary you know a lot
of these guys shout out to wear khaki is
really you know bringing attention to
your article and and seeing that
positive response from the community as
far as the things they want you know
like overall you know we all we all want
this game to be fixed we love it so much
you know but what do you what do you
hope to accommodate in motion you know
now that this is out there everyone is
pretty much in agreement with the doc as
far as what needs to be changing destiny
I mean for me there's two things right
the first is I want to just be able to
talk to people at Bungie like I would
love to just sit down and talk to them
and either have me tell me why my piece
is the stupidest worst thing in the
world or you know ideally they read it
and they go you know what we this gives
us some ideas on how to make the game
better and you know they take it they
make it better that's the ideal right so
they pageants the game and now we enjoy
it right now none of the patches are
gonna bring me back none of them will
get me to reinstall the game you know I
like the movements better you can like
it doesn't matter how fast you're moving
if there's nothing to chase yeah so
right now priority for you is that loot
is that is it that is it the weapon
system chain as far as getting stuff out
there they the heavy ammo spot or is it
just the fact that there's no more
randomize perked and everything it's
kind of static from per what or is it a
combination of both you need both of
those things I mean I would've got
installed
me back this is the flashpoint question
I would happen to flip the coin because
I could do either be there or like on
one hand having more synergistic perks
and better perks overall is gonna make
you know and and randomized perks is
gonna get me something to chase so
that's really important but if I don't
enjoy the moments of moment combat like
if I'm kind of bored of using you know
let's say they do bring back my cryptic
dragon and I get my hung jury at the
same time but your God roll the best
guns of like video game history like
country is in my opinion oh man one of
the best guns ever made a video game at
least with my role like the felt so good
to Iraq Jalal had that one that would
let me import my my entire arsenal that
would be amazing right but if they if
they brought that random chase back and
also I'd be really into it and I would
almost certainly reinstall play for a
bit the thing that's gonna keep me
around you know they're both gonna keep
me around right like playing a raid with
two Scout rifles it's still less fun
than like having that found verdict and
cryptic dragon that you're swapping
meaning adults it feels a little bit
better to switch between multiple kinds
of guns and have I'm getting into it a
bit with this new piece but it's my
argument is basically the the new sister
or the old system had more drama to it
like the opportunity to fail there were
opportunities to have high points low
points like I enjoyed it more because it
split things up yeah I mean so I would
love to see that come back to the game
and then there could be all sorts of
smaller changes like for instance right
now you get heavy ammo every single
round I think in trials mm-hmm it would
be nice to go back to the old school
like three versus three trials yeah
thank God please yeah but now I'm on
that train special so you could bring
that back and so it kind of cascades
into a lot of other possible changes
there for me really these two are the
two most important
you know and there's a few more things
that would help right like always having
more content is always important
absolutely so you know I mean the most
fun I've had playing a bungee game and
maybe the past year
well that was halo 3 because I co-opted
Ayla through friends but up after that
it was about four or five hours that we
spent in archons 4ch we got purple tip
is every single round get that salad
invidual did you get that salad
individual I don't think I got that this
time I think we got like any guns this
time but it was so because you like the
purple difficulty for like four hours
with two randoms those five total people
playing right so like if you wanna make
destiny to like a lot more fun
give me that random loot give me that
new you know the whole school gun system
that was making archons for so fun when
you bring back archons forage to like
yes you know carry as many keys as I can
collect yes let us manage in patrols on
us matchmaking these things you need
nailing it and the last one yeah exactly
like why are we being restricted why do
we have to go through hoops just to get
randoms in that should be a very
inclusive process and then the other
thing that you can also just you took me
to a place turns out that because the
Builder is great it's great because the
thing also I remember about is is if you
remember you could grind in our current
archons Forge and it was a specific
archons Forge armor set that the drop
rates were very low
yes like I loved that because it was
like a but a badge of honor like I
grinded this thing this activity the
drought rate was lower and I ended up
getting a full set of whatever that
armor was and it was just like yeah like
that guy he does all come forth and
people come up to you like where did you
get that
that looks so cool you know so it's
kinda like I'm in for a walk it's kind
of like a Cobra Commander looking at
helmet I believe so much but I love that
big oh I love it was my prize gale Hydra
my computer's occupied so I can't look
stuff up those are the moments those the
things from d1 that I really miss and I
know we're gonna get into the table in
in a second but it's all I can actually
take your point a little further so
before that let's go dig in an article
so one piece that I wanted to ask you
and I kind of forgot the other one but
it's fine on this one so have you ever
played World of Warcraft no okay so when
it comes to the progression of the game
and you may have talked about this in an
other article too what are your overall
thoughts and I'll kind of dig into this
a little deeper with regards to being
able to get max level by doing anything
was at its best during a house of wolves
okay I know there's a lot of people who
didn't like the hand can admit I'm not a
great player but I did not get killed by
thorn any more than any other you know I
never hated I never really felt like oh
man about the one this is the worst the
only thing I really hate it was when you
got hit it felt bad to die cuz it was
just taking too long to die so I love
that matter right and if you remember in
that meta they solved the forever 29
problem by giving you a CEREC light so
okay do this activity you get a thick
light
yes fit in you maxed out your gear and
you'll it lets you put it in any one
piece of gear so it's still required you
to play I believe the high level um
prison of elders I don't think it was
Colossus but I think it was one right
below that yes that is correct
and you know by the way I miss those
guys like I you know when they brought
it forward they didn't bring forward or
rocks or everybody else yeah it's like
20 boss is missing from the endgame that
should be there um but sir I got a
little bit of digestion um you know for
me that house of wolves was almost
perfect I think it was a little too easy
to reroute gear but other than that like
you could see you could get to next
level and there was an indictable path
to get to max level mmm but it wasn't
like some guy could hop in and grind for
you can get really lucky and get through
it it was like thank you I think you got
one or two or three glad a week saying
it was gonna table some time and it let
you upgrade certain pieces of gear but
then you might find other pieces of gear
that you were like hey I want to try
this and I've got an extra ethereal ight
now so I'm gonna try it so there was
like some planning and choice and
consequence votes yes that Dave removed
with the taken King mm-hmm and you know
I didn't like the taken King set up that
much because it was kind of random and
it didn't and we got like 85% of the
progress you know so when they brought
it back in Arezzo and they they fixed it
and ran some iron
I think reservoir was the best take on
the taking Kings approach mm-hmm and I
think destiny to fixes it a little bit
by not making ghosts I think ghosts own
affect your light now right now that's
correct which is nice but I think I
think rise of iron had the best for the
post taking King here but the best
effort for me was very good I've got mr.
first what time I've heard that me
mostly you hear taken King was like a
lot of people's gold in there and I
remember like house of wolves at first
the initial back Lac with bash lakhs was
like there was no rain or whatever but
the I do remember it Derrick light and
you actually you took me to a place did
well as well you know as far as that
whole those mechanics and stuff like
that you got anything on us oh my girl
Saban says before you jump into this
well no but the other pressure as you
talked about archons Forge and those
public event type things and just a way
that I've always wondered is what they
used to do a World of Warcraft as you
progress through there were certain
reasons to go do strikes or you had
certain activities you do as you
progress through and they would be a way
to get to different levels and as you're
saying with etheric light of a way to
level up what I would I wish they would
do to make the different things matter
and it's kind of what they used to do
but they feel like they took it away as
well and I could be wrong but when you
go through the story you get through the
story then if you want to do you know
then there was the other quest like they
didn't take in King but say there's also
strikes and then heroic strikes that get
you higher and then there's in game and
the public events could be somewhere in
the middle of that for a reason as you
said hey I want to grind this set and
I've done this but I'm working my way to
do this public of it
whatever to get - right ready so just
that type of progression - they have a
they have some content in the game that
has just wasted a lot and the waiting
whole thing of that stuff back to you
has adventures or heroic adventures why
are there only three heroic adventures
where the hell's the rest of the game
like nobody's played most of them so
different pieces to pull back in
absolutely every week they they have
like a they would sort their missions by
like I don't know if it was like planets
or what but like you usually do yeah
based on like I think there was like
Earth and Moon Venus and Mars whatever
you know so they have think these things
and there would be a playlist of all the
missions that took place on those two
locations so this is quite a large pool
by the Enix there were so many but it
felt good to be able to have those
heroic missions with the actual
modifiers in there and everything
absolutely but you know I mean I so
here's a preview of my next piece so
let's get that exclusive one things I
mentioned that I really want to see is
basically a nightfall patrol where you
go to the flash point plan for the week
okay it's night fell difficulty and
there's a cover or you know the the
burns or the modifiers whatever you call
them right there's in each section of
the map and I guess you get more as you
move from one section to the next no
fleet missions while you're there but
it's really you know it's really
difficult and you go on to say six
people you know because we love those
six player activities right yeah
absolutely
put bosses in each one of those sections
you know really and then maybe have no
revives at all okay if a player dies you
know you try to get to the next room of
the planet or whatever you call it you
basically work your way around that sir
that would be awesome and you know
basically get to the point where either
everybody's made it to the end or
there's one person left and they get
that clutch kill all right but like it
is if you all fail you get booted back
to orbit he'll let me even so say if you
started in trust land then you went to
the west you made kind of like a big
u-shape it was like zone one two three
and you like work your way through is
kind of
yeah essentially you'd have to fight a
boss in each I guess we call it a room
you know because there pretty much every
planets a circuit right you know you'd
start one way and you just follow it all
the way around and it gets progressively
harder as you go and you get better
leave we're gonna lean all the way
around and you have a whole plane out of
stuff sitting there already to do that
just use it like I'm not saying that's
easy to program still not a developer I
mean I've never even thought of that but
that's another way to compete raised
like patrols like heroic patrols I'm
playing monster hunter and you have
normal rank and then now you've got high
rank and you sit there and you take
stuff that you've done before and you
just crank everything up a notch and
there's they don't do that with very
much of their games so obviously sounds
like a blast
yeah absolutely so that's that's what I
want to see I think I've seen some a few
people mention that over time yes I
don't claim to be the most original
person it's like it's in the game it's
ready to go
the only way I could think to make even
that idea better is just to bring back
venus 2.0 oh yeah journey no be perfect
I loved being kicked back to urbanize I
hated it right because nobody wants to
but it was that tree the stakes yeah
exactly like failure was punished and I
feel like Bungie needs to be okay with
that they needed yeah they're they're
afraid of that
absolutely for the casuals and then just
throwing a legendary nightfall like if
you're gonna do the same in Halo right
normal heroic legendary just give us a
legendary nightfall or whatever I mean I
think they call prestige right yeah man
like go even harder crank at the
difficulty more just you know let me be
masochistic if I want I agree you know I
will suffer for that ice breaker right
like I got my nice and I think for my
first nightfall ever mmm-hmm
so it's one of my favorite guns of all
time it means a lot to me I remember
getting it I remember using it and
thinking this sucks and then going
oh now I understand how it works this is
the best gun ever yep and you just
nailed it and that that's everything
that's ultimately we want we that we
don't want it we want to prestige
activities to matter to means and that
goes into my whole narrative and I won't
get into it as a pontus knows how I feel
about we know you know there you know
how I feel about the whole light level
situation and and they still have not
addressed it and I've hit up CJ you know
specifically and I just want to know
what I what someone to explain to me
from lungi the thought process of light
level no longer mattering when you
jumped into a raid when you jumped into
trials you know I remember even I am
banner he's like okay damn even though
this weapon might not be the greatest
right now it pumps my light up and yes
was they you know I mean I was that was
that was the advantage so significant no
it's probably like points or something
but it rewarded the people who grinded
the game who had the highest like gear
and this should be no excuse that if I'm
doing a rail and we had a tectonic
flashpoint to gaming at it and we talked
about it like when the raid layer came
out and he's like kognito arm I want you
to join jump in and I might do it I'm
not a flight level I'm like only you
know 315 or whatever wasn't like it
doesn't matter I'm like are you serious
and I literally jumped in the new raid
layer eater of worlds it meant nothing
I was not dying any faster there was no
scalability and I'm like wow it just
really surprised me that I was able to
play high level content you know I'm
saying and I'll go into it for Holden
you know how I feel I want to push for
throwing off a cliff
I like the clan aspect I don't like you
know given out raid gear and and trials
gear to my clan that hasn't even touched
and stepped in we know we'll get into
this I let me let me calm down did let's
get into the swap let's get it today we
do got some positive stuff to talk about
you know the sea was good at all
so I mean you guys can read it on screen
like I can you guys haven't run it so
I'm here - I'm here to comment as well
so feel free to jump in
all right I'll let you let you kick it
off with the what they talking about
initially so this week at Bungie first
they talked about crimson days I mean
they basically just said you know the
decorations are up it's running they
have the full details we've you know I
talked about that in full depth of what
they were bringing back last week but
what do you guys think of it so far with
you've got the rewards on a checklist
you've got the engrams flowing just with
ease all over the place these certain
activities I'm kind of someone's stuff
up here but certain activities like the
night fog gets you a dance or the raid
gets you a skin I mean these are all
positive steps as you guys I'm saying
but for you know doc over there it's
like is any of this stuff even remotely
enough for people who left the game
right well for dr. st. bring it back
Saturday so I can't install any new
games you know let's say I've only got
room in some more more game do i do
Kingdom Come or do I do destiny - I'm
leaving Kingdom Come right now like like
I want to get back into destiny but like
a dance isn't gonna bring me back to
destiny
- I know at the end of the night Foley
gonna bring you back yeah exactly those
don't even do anything anyway
except for one or two exotic ones but
ghosts are more useless though whole
things in the game oh and by the way I'd
love to see artifacts but that's a
different matter entirely
oh yeah great to think those things
would all make my life better if I was
still playing the game but like crucible
for me is not fun because I can't
shotgun people like I was never a slide
shot or anything right or even that good
at the game but I you know I mean I'm
the guy who literally wrote Kotaku is
like best shot guns of all time list I'm
a very big gun guy
nice huh you would ever do that
[Music]
verdict more than felwinter's law we
found was lit I was like no party
crasher +2 I finally got a party crasher
and it had the range perks on it it was
neat but I hated using blanks you sound
a lot like me I love shotguns and I was
never a slide shot of your blink or
anything but I still just enjoyed like
Renner and corners me like sup yeah they
just like and it's just like it's that
satisfaction of like and now you're
looking am I gonna give up a rocket
launcher for my one to have you spot for
rocket no nobody's goes back B so I
think these are all good changes from
the like I thought about you know
talking about ever verse in my piece
right then I saw what they were doing
with crimson days I approved of at least
what it sounded like they were doing
well most people seem pretty happy with
it other than the length they wish it
would last longer right so you're me
like I can't complain or anything it's
great but it's not it's not gonna get me
to go back no I understand I mean I'll
just talk to her briefly from what I've
touched up obviously I just came back in
the stage touch crimson days briefly you
know the mechanic was kind of fun it was
a little cool you know when you stay
next to your partner and it's like leave
night it it says reunited at the bottom
left it's like a little stat buff and I
was definitely getting grenades a lot
and stuff like that and right shoutout
to the Nightstalker hunters were running
around invisible all day Jesus thing
going crazy oh Lord
but oh it fell fun there's a little
different spin on it you know um you
know the rewards and stuff like that
stuff was you know raining from the sky
that was cool you know and I think right
now is one of those things that yeah
this is a cool little mode you know it's
fun but at the same time yes is it
probably not enough and for me
specifically I'm just not a fan right
now everything is like I think like the
reward system is too much like ghost
Sparrow emblem and I'm like can I kick
some gear can I get like a gun like that
like yeah Gary Banzai
jumpin no no's I absolutely what you're
saying it's like all the stuff is still
I mean yeah they took the cosmetics and
they pulled him into ever verse and
right which is fine that would great
that's possible
but it was the big thing it's like did
you have to spend money on cosmetics to
change the way you played the game you
never did in the first place so they
haven't broken that line per se at least
in my eyes there was a lot of crap back
there which is one thing but as you're
saying it's like if you're gonna have a
vent be like hey if you want to play
that especially if you're gonna do it
for a week be like hey grind to level 10
and hey you might be able to get a gun
or if you grind through have like even
have shacks have another section to be
like you know if you grind the crap out
of this event you can go you know 2 4 6
8 it might get you a gun and you've got
an armor set for crimson days what did
you get that set when lid crimson I
played the crap out crimson days and
everything's cosmetic anyway but that's
like that's even more incentive if you
wanted it and in and that stuff's not
even in there I'll say there you know
destiny sized first-person shooters okay
yeah we're talking games that sell like
destiny and Call of Duty do yeah he got
he said he got interviewed to work at
Bungie and he almost took the job but
kind of hesitated because he felt they
were too reliant on data his middle ones
I'm looking at data and trying to find
like the perfect step thing even you
know you end up with the trip mind
getting a 3% nerf does that even do
anything I don't know alright but his
he's gonna take was like there's a
little bit to rely on data they spend
like they take really long periods of
time to come to decisions yes I mean
that's obvious by the sandbox update
obvious a bus young the games that this
guy has worked on the updates generally
come a lot faster mmm-hmm you know other
examples like the fortnight guys day
yeah all their data said that this one
grenade was perfect it was exactly where
it needed to be but you know what
everybody complained about it but even
those that said it was perfect
mmm-hmm everyone was complaining so they
listened to the community complaints to
it alright we're gonna change something
about the way the
feels yummy think this'll fix it so they
did in like a week
yes must did in like a week yes
apparently no more complaints about the
grenade I don't play fortnight so I
can't be 100 I heard that exact change
what fortnight and shot support that
guy's you making these I think quick
changes based on you know listening
people just hey what do you see hearing
and how are you feeling I think that's
gonna help I think the reason crimson
days doesn't have like a bunch of guns
and stuff is you know the reason guys
don't have multiple perks no stuff is
because Bungie so and again this is all
you know me being like I think it's an
informed opinion but it is my bohemian
base to bring somebody outside the game
I think Munchie is just they want to
take everything through a really lengthy
vetting process yes I would just like if
it were up to me right I would be like
screw it
here's the shotgun it has six rounds it
has really nice range we pulling that
one-hit kill range alot but like make it
a two shot at really long ranges it
feels nice you know I just be like dump
that in the game we'll see how it goes
for crimson well tune in next week and
you know I mean I can tune guns in
Unreal Engine in two minutes like I
literally just got the file I tweaked
one value I test it that's how long it
takes me I don't know why it takes
Bungie so long to do things no I think
you just nailed it I think you literally
answered your own question I think it's
it's literally that vetting process and
really over analyzing that data they're
very data heavy you know and um III
completely agree with that I think that
it's it's a very slow approach and at
the same time it's like balance is one
thing but if your base is saying that
this is in fun I mean I said that on one
of mine cuz you sorry to interrupt so
knows what I said before when we were
waiting for the big update on like
January at 11th or 10th or whatever that
was when we were yeah what do it 11th
yeah yeah when we were all sitting on
Twitter waiting for that f5 I was
literally I said that message to you
cockney you know I was like
the tension is palpable like and we're
waiting on an update from a developer
and we're gonna crucify them either way
they're not gonna be able to live up to
the hope of this giant bar we're hoping
to be like they're gonna make our game
better I'm like that stuff's gonna take
like destiny to to point out like taking
King it's gonna take that long and what
you're at the point where it's like
there's something the biggest thing is
it's fun
yes where's the like again that's kind
of where I led to I was like a game
should be fun if you don't find this
game entertaining and enjoyable
there are hopefully other games out
there that do that no game should bring
you to the point of hatred anger stress
anything like that because that's not
what they're for if you don't find this
fun and you feel those emotions go do
something else because it's not healthy
for you everyone said are they messed up
the weapons too powerful I don't know
data gets one gun wrong like that but it
was awesome like getting it wrong was
the best thing they do they're like okay
so we have the one you know the one
Prometheus says we can we're nerfing it
I'm over if you're going guys just make
a laser tag mode like my favorite though
bring that back for destiny it's like a
playlist I mean I like shotgun snipers
from Halo bring that back you know do
weird stuff and don't worry about a lack
of balance right like I said if you're
in there more frequently you know I'm
saying they can make you know make those
Tunes and adjustments that that's needed
so it's just like III completely hear
where you guys let's cut you a little
bit cuz I know we'd run a little over I
definitely wanna get into the rest is so
you want to scroll down on rally going
on these are coming back so they did fix
the well now sectors basically if you
kill a boss there's no timer just if you
kill a boss you lose the chat once and
it's fixed so you know they got the bug
taken care of which is good same armor
sets us before so still the same ones
that you're working on if you got your
full new monarchy set then a maybe no
current for something else
they didn't say there's going to be more
weapons within the packages as opposed
to just the sidearms
yes I saw that so now it looks like
they've added armed new weapons to the
pool as opposed just a one winning
weapon from you know the winning you
know the potential winning weapons from
the following week right now so we have
the Scout rifles from last time on the
lower picture and then up on the top it
looks like I don't know what this one's
gonna be maybe a pulse rifle because the
barrel still looks longer oh yeah yeah
so there you go got a power weapon this
looks probably around a pulse down below
on the bottom okay understanding a real
smart right now nope there's no pulse
rifle here is it was all auto rifles
last week that's why I forgot okay see
if I just get farther I'll catch up so
all pulls two pulse rifles and the big
old future work hold a scout rifle so
but there's more variety in the ignores
which is nice yeah I haven't been
playing as much I think it again reskin
all your guns the guns can feel a little
bit less exciting like treads between
stars and vision of confluence are the
exact same model but a distant one there
was only one skin per gun so they felt
different here I like I mean that one
auto rifle up above looks like valleca
did yes yeah let's call it the future
Walker looks like origin story yeah like
I'm not really you know I'm not really
sold like I already have tarantula why
do I want that dead orbit gun you know
there's exciting but like I'm not like
I'll just put the same you know no I
understand which goes which goes into
your whole point article as far as the
loot and the lack of the randomized
roles you don't saying I understand it
does it make the loop as exciting you
know
ah here you go it could continue about
this with DITA rusty yep so you got
Pulse Rifle Pulse Rifle and scout rifle
again you know you can pick but honestly
you can pick one per character so doof
action really is really even matter if
you've got three characters no I mean
they really don't tend to anymore much
for me so the other piece was we've got
the fine-tuning on I'm just kind of
going past you know where's there's not
much new there so we've got the
fine-tuning on the exotics now I read
through this and you guys can give me
your thoughts on it as well so their
goals for the gameplay for this pass
which of course is literally you just
got done saying these basses take way
too long like they want to add or
increase the power spike so I actually
have a you know a little more effective
feel focus on lo you so much items
specifically but of course still try and
catch everything they want to also lean
into an items establish gameplay and
then push it harder so so in general
they're talking about graviton Lance for
example so they said the functional
concept is that haven't fired two rounds
instead of third the ideas it fires two
rounds and supposedly it makes like bait
you can think of it as like a vacuum so
it just travels insanely fast and does
that bigger burst of damage but the
recoil is too much the feel didn't feel
right so they want to go through and
unfortunately when I read through this I
don't need to read all the description
of it it still sounds not enough
alright let me jump in let me jump in
real quick like I was trying to be
general so dodge Dan and this is this is
this is actually I think I had the
opposite of field because for me it was
like when I read this section I remember
this was one of my battle cries for d1
and I'm like I used to have like you
know from one thing like warlock stuff
like the stag and in d1 and I'm thinking
of like useless exotics in D word that I
would be like damn this looks so cool
but there's really no effective
functionality for completely useless
absolutely oh I used to preach I used to
being ready nice to be in um forms and
I'm like why are they so hesitant
to buff exotic armor and like it's my
specifically arm they would touch
weapons more I would say that not to
they didn't touch weapons at all but I
always felt armor for some reason so
when I see this kind of stuff even
though they haven't met and even though
they mentioned specifically graviton
lance which is a weapon but I am getting
a little excited because I like the
sentence where they like focus on low
usage items and that's my key because my
thing is you got the damn data
you guys are so data heavy right you've
got to know no one's using you know what
with the star light star fire protocol
for the for a warlock the one I gave you
the two you know what you call it like
you've got you have this information so
why are we so afraid to even touch or do
anything with these low usage exotics
and then the last thing I liked which
was on as far as leaning into an items
establish gameplay and push it harder I
like that mean let's be honest with thee
we talked about it you know last
flashpoint so when we were like now at
the inclusion of masterworks right and
it's giving these orbs and stuff like
that now masterworks are making these
legendaries making the exotics
absolutely but i can literally run a
full masterwork set you know of weapons
and it's like i don't want to put on
merciless i don't want to put on any
exotic weapon because i'm not gonna have
that orb generation that i'd like i love
with the inclusion of masters so when I
see stuff like this
I get excited maybe I'm overexcited no I
was gonna say I do agree on that stuff
the low usage stuff I haven't more what
the changes they're doing to graviton
Lance don't feel like enough and if
that's the feel of what they're going
for but I mean if they do bring low
usage items up that I am a hundred
percent for because there's a lot of
stuff that sits in my vault you know I
was complaining that the edges off right
so having player power spikes that
sounds exciting to me instead of high
usage that makes me happy because I mean
I wrote a whole article about how they
focus on low usage and that's our high
usage unit sucks Louise
so this makes me excited you know and I
like the idea of hey let's try to make
the identity of each thing just a count
more like all of this is great right but
then every graviton LAN city since a
really time talking about zero air
resistance tunnels the high power
precision shots like I don't know what
any of that means right
conceptually in a sci-fi universe I get
it right but dude there's nothing to do
with gun function and that that fantasy
is and what sold me on the gun mm-hmm
sold me on the gun was is like you know
it's a what is it like a pulse rifle
that basically has Firefly yeah pretty
much like the Lena Firefly like it
really wasn't as effective yeah so like
it had all the disadvantages of all
those things where I could have just had
a Firefly scout rifle I had more fun so
you know he says he says somewhere in
here that it gets a slight mathematical
edge against other pulse rifles and like
yeah I want all my exotics to be bit
like straight-up better than my
legendaries you know my Yeller horn
should be better than my I don't I can't
think of a stephen hunger across yeah so
it needs to better than that you know my
universal remote should be better than
everything even though it's universal
remote so it's the worst can ever you
know I'm joking I thought it was pretty
fun gun you know primary shotgun that's
amazing right
but graviton Lance doesn't sound
exciting cuz it's like crimson right
crimson is Red Death but with less ammo
and less accuracy and range so little
bit of workers like the same thing it's
my um it's my freakin what you call my
hung jury unless but let's you know I'm
stay you sucka like they're making it
more powerful relative to destiny to you
guns I want it to be on par with destiny
one guns which is a big ask I know but I
don't care like should I care it's the
sequel it should be bigger and better
mm-hmm no I hate yeah I mean I totally
hear what you're going with there as far
as the power of fantasy and you know I
mean I guess when I read this graviton
lasting I wasn't as disappointing maybe
it's both you guys are but um I
Stan what you guys are saying it in
retrospect you guys are correct that
even with these this specific type of a
buff to graviton Mars
this still is not in line with like you
say like a hung jury from d1 yeah that's
what makes me go hey this sounds exotic
like dying
it's me interested mm-hmm I like that
and I like you know with the whole
ragdoll part of the body instead of it
you know what the flying back was not of
range you know I'm saying that the
defeated opponent floats back up makes
the explosion bigger increases the
damage you don't saying like that to me
is cool so I got a good below for me
yeah I gotta blow props for that one I
think in theory we gotta see how it is
in in practice right we do still need to
see it but you know in theory what they
say it sound okay you know and I'm with
you on that one too where it's like in
theory some of this stuff can be cool
but as I think I'm with doctor basically
be like when it comes to exotics if I
have to that I'm gonna put in any slot I
want it to be a tough decision that
whichever way I pick it's gonna be it's
gonna change the way I play but in a way
that both are noticeably different but
notice will be fun just fair enough fair
enough and it's not a big enough
difference then it doesn't have
literally does it live up to its name of
exotic and that was the one of the ones
in the giant update that hurt me the
most I was like we want exotics to feel
exotics and there's a point where I'm
gonna leave the curse word out but
you're like no kidding
it doesn't literally live up to the word
exotic like rare spell like all of those
things then why are you calling it that
making process should be picking between
that's actually true statements
you know the final round effort each
Spears is something else it would be I
think I had one with armor-piercing
rounds before the nerve you know you
could fight around and punch somebody
through cover like it was it was very
strong and I love it though no doubt No
so what about that last paragraph you
guys so about the UM as he goes on and
he says you know as far as the weapons
the exacts that are not getting an
update he lets you know merciless
Telesto what could call my name OH -
Carly legend of a Korean vigilance wing
and then he goes on to explain about how
vision swing they're already gonna
benefit from these a plan pulse
update pulse rifle update I'll jump in
real quick I didn't necessarily get to
cuz I know a lot of you guys are not
playing anymore especially not I get to
with these guys being off the list
because I actually feel these ones for
the most part are effective merciless to
me is great PvE Telesto I don't know I
maybe maybe disagree with the last one I
take that back work of course still
beast for the most part you know except
it when it's a far away kind of target
close yeah my de is my de you know it's
always gonna be that that stand of
functionality in my opinion Carly me and
doctors went into this a lot offline
nothing not the greys and PvE but PDP
man it's just to to thing you know two
shots around a corner and those Striders
and those those roaches they get you
legends a curious I felt um is really
dominant in the right hands I play a lot
of PvP and I felt like it the range on
that shotty is ridiculous and the fact
it can actually kill guardians grouped
up together you know it's it's it's a
really powerful PvP a decent PvE for for
yellow bar vigilance wings I got a see
I'm gonna give them the benefit of doubt
because I like it in practice I still
don't feel it's as effective as it
should be
vigilance is mostly just a five shot
burst or what else yeah like do
something that that means something else
Telesto if it's still just like destiny
one and you're not gonna touch it then I
don't know yeah I was like some of these
I mean mercilessness yeah it's I mean
for BB it serves its purpose very well
something like word cliff coil I wish
when they talk about like say exotic
masterworks take something like the
exotic masterwork for war cliff coil and
say you know one or two
of how everybody Rockets to be out of
that thing because I've never counted
say one or two I'll hit your target
picture we'll go three that's true
that's true and and you know take those
in escalate them I agree I agree and
actually made a good point what work of
co2 because if you remember when doing
the Leviathan that was one of my
effective weapons for doing the the bats
when you had to shoot those chandelier
things yeah
and for whatever reason they just a
limit it's useless now like they nerfed
it because they didn't like the
effectiveness of you getting rid of the
chandeliers that if everybody ran war
cloth calling this goes to Doc's point
it's like that heavy-handed kind of nerf
that was kind of fun that you like why
no one's complaining like why why do we
need to do this like literally you pull
out work lift call now and the people
who run the Leviathan reign knows you go
to the royal baths you have to run to
the center there's three sets of
chandeliers at the top and what work
lift was so effective and I was just
like why is it now it literally does no
damage to these things like it's so I'm
just like I don't get it it's like the
shotgun version of Yeller horn I mean
it's literally just they've reduced the
range if you put yellow horn in the game
you'd have two guns that basically I
don't always win because it's better so
I wish forklift could kind of push into
a different kind of strength maybe you
know maybe like going hey it won't kill
you it's the only rocket launcher that
won't kill you if you blow it up close
or something you know
I'd love to see your generation back
until let's do like this new one yeah I
wish Merciless had more ammo yeah you
know I'm the guy who's famous shotgun
has 180 rounds you know the colony needs
the bug fix I don't think they've ever
done the book correct for PC like it
might uh um they should add a really
useless buff to it just for fun which is
it should point you in the direction of
treasure chests that's the only because
that used to be a rumor of a feature the
gun had yeah right
make the gun more powerful or anything
it's just a dumb little perk like that
would be great
my neighbor got a curious like I got the
first tier of it but I haven't done the
prestige right Greece's beast man I got
the full-fledged version accuracy is
felwinter's lie d1 but actually better
the only weakness to actress is that I
believe it's like 2 in the clip before
you have to reload and the reload is
pretty terrible but you know it's
perfect to try to I guess inanimate
areas to balance the weapon but legend
actress the full version its beast I'm
gonna have to eventually complete the
rated yeah I wish they would just shrink
the model size like yes to be extra
doofy that's the only reason I never use
it
but this does imply the Jade rabbit is
gonna be fixed which makes yes cuz Jade
rabbit is terrible and out as an Xbox
guy who finally got Jade rabbit now oh I
was so disappointed 2.0 all over again
for Xbox guys he's nerved version of a
copper gun that everyone was praising
and then we get it and it's like yeah
here you go here's the stripped down
super boring not fun not damaging scout
that I'm wasting an exotic slot for I
always liked that gun in PvP is amazing
as a PvP gun does anyone do you want a
bootleg Jade rabbit t-shirt because my
spawn animation it is there's awful
hunter exotic pants like I love the Jade
rabbit fixed I want them to be like okay
this gun needs to be a beast but you
want a good continue on or what the with
the rest of data that segment yeah
there's not too much else I mean they
just talked about you know couple
clarifications for crimson days the burn
out map
is here and then will be joining the
crucible rotation which is good you've
got the two sparrows one from completing
the activity the other one is just just
just to back you up one second they did
talk about they're gonna talk about
exotic master works soon yeah that was
cool
sorry just what I didn't want to forget
that one cuz I would definitely
something I at least be personally
excited for cuz I do like master works
you know saying so to see what they do
with that but continue with the crimson
clarity stuff and then just had the
undeterred exotic Sparrow earned by
participating in the playlist does not
come from the in Graham so you actually
have to get it that way and then the
undefeated exotic Sparrow does come from
the end Graham so it's on the list so
they're knock out list hopefully sounds
like it's working as intended they just
apparently needed to clarify that and
then outside of that she got your movies
of the week and they sat down below
still a few more days of 2v2 and then we
were all into faction rallies have been
joined grabbing a partner we're always
interested in your thoughts and some
feedback and all that fun stuff so that
pretty much wraps up you know this week
a punji not too much else there yeah
yeah man I mean look you know I didn't
expect too much and then we had crimson
days going on didn't expect too much
other than that to be honest I mean I'm
excited I'm a low-key lover faction
Riley
you know I pretty much got all my new
Marquis gear coordinates set right now I
don't know I don't think we may have
missed this on they did mention I think
ibly they didn't mention the whole lost
sector controversy remember how they had
that timer yeah well I mean I covered it
briefly but they have the patch in there
they do the whole so there is no more
timer it's just if you kill that boss
you loot the chest you have to you know
you just can't redo that one but if you
know that when you're fine
yes so those you know corner in the
event of you know not trying to be the
fun police again and stop what people
are doing and stuff like that so you
know see how that goes but you know
obviously we still you know need more
I'm still looking for that that whole
development roadmap and when they get
into you know which was the date was
like March I believe was the date that I
was the most excited about because I'm
they really gonna get into
sandbox changes and stuff like that as
far as the roadmap is concerned that
really has me excited you know I mean I
believe it was the March 27th and that's
when we get um iron banner 66 I want to
see how that go they really gonna dive
deep into the sandbox changes and stuff
like that so you know you know I kind of
just still like the holdout period for
me specifically for the changes I want
you know I mean kind of deal but overall
what was your impressions on Ibanez with
this week's swap I mean yeah thank you
pretty well-covered it was pretty mild
packs and rallies is coming they're
giving you a couple more weapons but I
mean is it enough if you stepped away
for a little bit or if you're playing
another game to be like do I really want
another painting or another that's what
I said and he said it too it's like you
have the same skin I'm just throwing a
different coat of paint on it it doesn't
do a lot for me so if I've got my new
monarchy said and I think that one's the
coolest I'm not really gonna go grind
another set just for another character
probably not doesn't do me much so the
exotic pass basically just crossing my
fingers that they do enough as we're
saying I just hope that there's there's
enough difference in an exotic versus
any legendary that I really makes me you
know want to use an exotic mmm
absolutely most of mine so we just at
this point could wait and see you but
I've been playing a ton of Monster
Hunter so the overall is yeah but we
still got a ways to go for me you're
fully all the way commit back to our
that's these life counter digs that we
stay out ways so doc in the building
kane drew the man who broke the internet
it's good to have you man also you know
I know these changes probably per say
yeah you know where they're gonna get
you to come back right right now but up
based on what you read this week you
know what was your your thoughts so far
there's nothing that disappoints me or
or you know turns me off right you know
it's all like hey if I was still playing
this would be great but
you know if I was still playing right so
right what I want to see from Bungie
really is something big something huge
like straight up going Venus is back you
know something that large that's what's
gonna bring me back but you know for
this for the like you know it's a really
good band-aid it's gonna maybe stop the
bleeding for people who haven't left
already but may have been considering it
what but I think for the people like me
we're not totally lost you know I'm
still a distant one right you know it's
got the awful you know special animal
meta you know I prefer that to destiny
seed right now so hopefully they can
bring me back you know
know do i I want to come back like more
than anything that's the one thing I
wants no doubt well they worked like I
said there was a basically there was a
hint and I mean I know bronzers had
talked about it before where they said
ah what was the exact terminology uh
wants what he was talking about and
weapons slot allocation or sin all day
like that and it was like you're like
that could mean maybe yeah
because they said I mean they say
sandbox changes and all those things but
you're talking about weapons slot
allocation you're like there's only so
many ways to take that if you start
screwing with the weapon slots you have
to be talking about what we're hoping
for more at least or I'm completely
clueless like it's something I can't
even think of cautious somewhere
hopefully in the background Luke Smith
is working on the team for taking King
2.0 or whatever it's called and they're
like alright guys taking King throw
destiny 11.0 out the window we're doing
stuff like what I think it's gonna take
for people like doc to be like yeah
alright I'm ready to dive back in for a
good solid month I'm not just gonna pick
it up blow through the campaign be like
yeah it's like it needs the full rework
and I agree that's what I completely
agree I think in order for this game to
be saving these there's these
incremental changes that I think have to
come to a build and they need to kinda I
don't know if they can do it again this
is a hard-ass but they need to have a
taken king moment you know in September
because you know even in this next one
which was should be May I believe
there's a lot of changes that are
positive you know sample will that even
be enough you know and I think though
core changes in Doc's article loot you
know I'm saying randomization you know
random roles weapon slots placement and
either just some way of approaching the
key will be how dug in are there with
this system that nobody likes as far as
primaries right special isn't heavy
like how dug in are they development
wise will they make that commitment and
not to be honest I think that that
really you know that that that hinges on
the future of destiny as far as where it
goes as again I mean we all saw what
happened to division right you know we
we have real-life examples that if you
don't make these specific changes that
the community wants if your needs going
I mean we see lucky guys are playing
mind to Hunter its Baron out here man
you got dado you got you got you know
famous content creators from destiny not
making destiny context to the point of
destiny one came out in a time when
people got hooked when there was less
competition you've got the viral piece
of pub G got for tonight you've got a
whole new world especially in PC you've
got a lot of people that if they were
gonna like it this thing has to be
awesome because people who are hooked on
other awesome things yeah I mean and
it's free I think every single gun in
the game including good ones shots fired
power fantasy why don't we play video
why are we Guardians because if we want
to feel like badasses it's literally
that simple and when you take away the
feeling like when it feels monotonous
with the team shouting if it's just no
gun feels cool
there's no point so exactly the one
thing last week I know you guys weren't
around but it when they had talked about
the activision call yes so that was a
just a brief little sidebar what I mean
so they say a major expansion in the
second half
right now typically but you know Bungie
and Activision I'm sure they have their
really schedule where it's like it's
likely to fall in September now you've
got Red Dead Redemption in October which
is going to be a big poll from
everything which is terrifying for
anything in October
but me what I would rather see is it
technically to still be the second half
but something like give me December 15th
take three more months and make this
game what we want let people play the
other things or even I don't mean it
piss off Activision's investors and it'd
be hard yeah but I'd rather see them do
it right and taking King 2.0 otherwise
you are probably almost done yeah
if take yeah I agree I mean if they
don't that that expansion to me is the
only chance to get a guy like Doc back
right I think they can do it sooner than
that like I have to wait until I got a
buy a DLC that a lot of people are
saying they like but I don't know if I'm
gonna like work for me if you remember
like Diablo 3 right they brought in
weapon AIDS 2.0 in patch 2.0 point 1 no
and that update is what saved the game
then came along later and they brought
in that really juicy expansion Reaper of
souls that everybody had yeah but it was
weapon update 2.0 point 1 or 2 point out
that came earlier that is what saved
Diablo 3 so I would like to see you know
it doesn't have to be polished doesn't
have to be flawless but just bringing
back that randomized loot and that
old-school gun system they already have
all the data so it's totally doable you
know bring that in maybe let me import
my old gear if possible maybe add one
planet from the original game even if
it's the you know mercury even its
whatever this monster the moon this
mustn't worry but if you like you Phobos
what's that remembered to do oh yeah you
know bring a bunch of small stuff in
that ideally doesn't take too long does
it require a lot of new resources just
nothing changes up the flow of the game
makes the game feel good and once you
have that then I'll buy the DLC because
right now even if it's the taking king
sized expansion
I'm glad monster hunter this fall I
probably won't be playing a lot of
destiny unless I'm already back into
destiny now here's the enemy he's the
question for you Donna Summer - I hear
you on the summer patch so you're saying
that even you need your weapon stuff you
need all that lose them you need that
prior anything yeah gotcha
Phaneuf men if you win them over in the
summer you get people back and playing
it then if you do a later expansion even
then you know then you still got at
least hooked and they may fade off
because other things may come out people
are gonna play red dead but you've at
least get a positive experience in the
game so when that comes out they're like
sweet I'm ready for it as opposed to
Emma do I know absolutely I just the
system change is what I need is what you
need know and I and I hear the reddit
community the forums and I see people
say the exact same thing Haven till they
bring but you know my heavy using you
know stuff back and you know then didn't
talk to me you know yeah I see it
I see the comments consistently so
you're not far off and as your article
already proved you are the heartbeat of
the community right now we gonna wrap
this thing up sooner we went a little
bit over but a shout out the dock
amnesia in the building red coming
through the man the myth the legend men
who broke ready it broke the inner has
the entire community in a frenzy where
can the fine people find you and what
else do you have cooking up well you can
find me on Twitter I'm a freelance
writer so you know I got a piece coming
which would be Oh sort of like the
changes I want to see so they'll be a
little bit more concrete okay wait a
week what are we looking forward to get
met when was offering I want to see next
week because the first step is done but
it's 48 hundred words long
so cut 1,600 words and then it's gonna
take my editors a few days to get to it
so though maybe mid next week so I've
got that Kotaku has an article from me
that they've just been sitting home for
a week
had a game on a budget or something ice
about saving money buying video games
so got that going and they don't have a
new piece for them soon which might be
on Batman
you know what it is yet we just agreed
to do another one in February you know I
got a review for IGN on the survival
game rust coming out you know I'll be
writing that Sanskrit for my own blog
soon as well as somebody picked me to
write about Final Fantasy 15 and streams
and Resident Evil 4 so no doubt man
appreciate it man love your work very
passionate this guy's this guy's
hardcore desi man this is not just be
clear for people who are not familiar
with dark like this is not from a place
from hate or just random you know
senseless bashing this is a person who
is definitely committed to the franchise
who loves the game wants to see you get
back to his glory it was really
refreshing to read your article and I
really liked what you doing man so thank
you for coming on the flash point I'm
happy to have you know that ebon tis
good to be back man boys do a flat
weight without oh well yeah I was a
little different without you I just had
to record on my own I'm like crap I
talked for half an hour but here we go
hope people like hearing me but yeah
when you say you're right 4,800 words
I'm like I'm worthy to a point where I
know you've done journalism so your
practice mine would be much worse than
yours if I wrote an article about that
so yeah I praise you for you know what
you're doing because believe me if I
sent you one you'd be like try again you
wrote way too much we're gonna get some
Kade stashes going on we're gonna get
what we doing Montebello we got looking
for no no it's just with work and stuff
my reset was a little later in case -
this week I'll keep those going like
resets but I do want to get some Monster
Hunter stuff going cuz I'm just having
way too much fun with that game right
now
I just got to uh if you guys knew it I
took out a large how do I say dragon of
that is the color black and that fight
solo when you're going through the story
progression that was rough so like if I
I had a nice fist bump moment there but
I want to get some stuff up there about
that one is his weapon guides and yeah
just follow me on youtube and
and I try and stream on Twitch what I'm
playing on things so it's Eve on Tess
everywhere you can find me so absolutely
man it's not Lido here glad to be back
in the States and talking destiny
obviously you know the on Lord podcast
will return they will be returning this
Sunday at 1:00 p.m. Eastern that is the
Lord's Day please make sure you guys
stop by our gonna have a great show and
it's always fun to be doing these little
flash points and also I got some stuff
cooking up may have something going on
with uh know what Jake finds a relly you
may be talking some of my combat sports
as well so look out be on the lookout
for that but uh man this was a fun show
and good to get back in the routine of
doing flashpoints and let people and the
Destiny community know that uh is it
safe to come back yeah we all we all
love this game we love the game we just
wanted to improve what those fields from
d1 that dock and ebon says were
mentioning and you know hopefully 1g
tuna can listen and really start to
apply these changes in a prompt fashion
so that's all I got and we want to enjoy
the night and wrap this thing up I guess
people have a good one